[Music]
hey what's up world we are live here at
the voice finale hanging out with the
two guys behind the summer anthem the
hit of the summer I'm calling it right
now despots eat though he got Luis FONSI
and daddy yankee I heard you singing the
song a little bit ago I told you stuck
in my head I can't get it out that's a
great problem I haven't not thank you so
much I appreciate that
yes see for those who don't know what is
despots eat don't mean slowly slow slow
slow - granny - granny slow you know
like that it like that you know that's
not either slow it down and Juggalo me
down so obviously uh the the song was a
hit on its own I mean went to number one
the minute you guys dropped it but then
they get a remix with mr. Justin Bieber
I had to imagine I was going to
skyrocket from there right it was it was
a great call man it was a great call to
to know that beaver you know heard the
song he was in Columbia doing his tour
he saw people reacted to it he reached
out to us and he's like hey can I jump
on the remix and when I guess sir I mean
he did his thing you know he's saying
his verse in English he sang the course
in Spanish um you know so we're that was
awesome yeah we're going to nobody was
expecting that right like he's singing
in Spanish I think that what that makes
that the ring even better yeah then he
was true he was true to the original and
we had an English lyric for everything
and he's like no no no I'm gonna do this
in Spanish he took the time to enunciate
everything and to do it the right way so
I think it's a big win for Latin music
and we're talking to have such a huge
global star you know collaborate with us
you did a good job whether you think
Biebs got a future in Latin music I
meant next the next thing of Justin
Bieber seeing salsa you can do it man
he's a talented kid and I respect among
ya nothing but love man you sure
you